What's the last thing anyone expected
to see in the first episode of She-Hulk?
How about busted tech from MCU Phase 2? Here's
the history behind the surprising memento.
The Marvel Cinematic Universe has thrilled
audiences on the big and small screen for
more than a decade, and in all that time there's
only been one in-universe version of the Hulk.
Bruce Banner was originally played by Edward
Norton in "The Incredible Hulk" before Mark
Ruffalo came aboard for "The Avengers" — but
it's the same character in the MCU. However,
the hero has been joined by a brand new Jade
Giant, Jennifer Walters, also known as She-Hulk,
played by Tatiana Maslany of "Orphan Black" fame.
Jen gets her powers from Bruce's blood when they
get into a car accident due to a Sakaarian ship
showing up out of nowhere — a seeming
nod to the "World War Hulk" comics.
The series kicks things off by establishing
a fun dynamic between the two cousins,
as "Professor Hulk" tries to teach Jen
everything there is to know about being a Hulk.
Speaking to Access Hollywood in February,
Ruffalo had high praise for Maslany
"Frickin' legendary as the She-Hulk.
I'm passing the 'banner' onto her."
Ruffalo added,
"There are some really good, funny, cool, long,
long scenes between Professor and
her. We've never really seen the Hulk
interact with people the way he does in
that show. It'll be really interesting."
Bruce and Jen spend plenty of time in
the isolated Mexican laboratory where the
scientist learned to merge his two selves in
the time between "Avengers: Infinity War,"
and "Avengers: Endgame." But when Walters is
wandering around the building, she finds a
bittersweet Iron Man memento that has us all
in our feelings. Here's why it's so familiar.
Although "She-Hulk" is obviously
about Jennifer Walters and how
she balances her legal career alongside her
burgeoning responsibilities as a superhero,
the show also takes the opportunity to
look at Bruce Banner a little more closely.
Episode 1 reveals that Bruce spent a lot of
time with Tony Stark in the five-year "Blip" gap
after "Avengers: Infinity War," because
the billionaire playboy philanthropist
funded his laboratory. They even built a
beach-side bar together to have some fun,
even in a traumatic time. But Bruce seems
to have done more of the work than his pal.
"Well, Tony mostly drank, just sat
around, like, complaining about Steve."
When Jen is wandering through the house, she finds
a ruined Iron Man helmet that Bruce is clearly
keeping to remember his fallen friend. It seems
like the black-and-gold helmet could be from a
Mark XX Python suit, which briefly shows up with
several other suits at the end of "Iron Man 3."
Fans will remember that Bruce briefly appears
in the post-credits scene of the 2013 movie,
nodding off while listening to Tony
ramble on. But the Mark XX suit blows up,
on Tony's orders, after the final big
battle in "Iron Man 3," so it's way
more likely that the memento is actually an
Iron Legion droid head from the "Avengers:
Age of Ultron" era. These unwearable suits
were ultimately used against the Avengers
when Ultron — who was developed with
Bruce's help — took control of them.
This little memento reminds us that Tony
and Bruce had a real friendship that thrived
outside of saving the world. When the two first
meet in "The Avengers," Tony tells Bruce that he's
a big fan of his, especially when he grows into an
"enormous green rage monster." Over the years we
see them connect and grow as friends, working on
projects and driving around in supercars together.
Using a small part of "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law"
to look a little closer at Hulk's character arc is
a clever move from Marvel. After all, the giant
hero hasn't had his own solo movie since 2008,
since the distribution rights for
the character are at Universal,
so any MCU Hulk action is a welcome turn
of events, even on the small screen.